just a quick fYI I was introduced to a
new phrase just now hot off the presses
I think this is the newest trendiest
phrase on the left here it is okay
non-consensual puberty yes yes
non-consensual puberty this apparently
refers to when like a trans boy is
forced to go through puberty against his
will which makes him even more
apparently male which he doesn't want to
be so that's that's non-consensual
puberty which which honestly I can I can
relate to that I mean I I am
experiencing right now non-consensual
aging and eventually I will
non-consensual II die so it is it could
be very very tough thing so look out for
that you're gonna be hearing that more
and more especially if you happen to go
to college which I don't recommend
anyway this is kind of related actually
let's talk about let's talk about
Gillette the best a man can get
supposedly which which was always a
questionable slogan because men really
shouldn't be shaving at all as you could
I don't know a lot about you Gillette as
you can tell and as if to drive that
point home
you know as if Gillette wanted to drive
home the point that you know what don't
use our product don't shave they came
out with an ad if you can call it an ad
which encourages men to shave off their
toxic masculinity and to you know to
stop being generally so horrible you see
men men really haven't been lectured and
scolded and sermonize too enough so
Gillette decided they were going to get
in on the act I think the people at
Gillette the the advertising you know
folks there they sat around and they
said okay we're trying to sell razors
we're trying to sell shaving cream how
can we get more men to buy this stuff
and then they all kind of looked at each
other and they said we need to tell them
that they're awful and yeah you know
what they need a homily that's what they
need they need
Chameli and everyone they all nodded in
agreement and they said let's do it
brilliant I should mention by the way
that all of the in this in this scenario
all of the advertising people in July
they are all college aged feminists
apparently and and so this is the ad
they came up with I mean it is it's
being hailed as wonderful and inspiring
mostly by by liberals feminists of
course love it as I said I think
feminists probably are the ones who came
up with this and when feminists love an
ad that's supposedly made for men you
know that something's wrong so let's uh
let's take a look here's the ad right
now
bullying the meter men against
masculinity is this the best a man can
get
is it we can't hide it's been going on
far too long
[Applause]
we can't laugh at all
[Applause]
what I actually think she's trying to
say making the same old excuses but
something finally changed and there will
be no going back because we we believe
in the best in men men need to hold
other men accountable smile sweetie come
on to say the right thing to act the
right way
[Music]
saman already are in ways big
oh [ __ ] and smoky eyes Joel
but some is not enough some who treat
each other
[Music]
because the boys watching today will be
the men of tomorrow okay so a few things
here first of all the ad says and
another you know there are a lot of us
has a lot of feminists and I've seen
plenty of women not just women but also
liberal men on social media who are
saying well what's the problem with this
thing you know it seems it seems fine to
me what's - it's it's it's inspiring
right what's what's wrong with inspiring
men well there's a lot wrong with it I'm
gonna try to explain it to you now
first the ad says that something changed
okay and there's no going back
and then as soon as it says that then we
see all these scenes of men doing normal
decent things like breaking up fights
between kids refraining from sexually
harassing women and the thing that's
supposed to be the catalyst the thing
that supposedly changed everything had
made men see the error in their ways is
the me2 movement right
the me2 movement and you hear this all
the time that the me2 movement came
along and made men look at themselves
and rethink things and come to
realizations and have epiphanies this is
also a lot of the men who were caught up
in the me2 movement a lot of the
Hollywood celebrities who were who were
exposed as perverts when they came out
with their inevitable apologies they
would always have a line like this they
would say well you know the me2 movement
I think it's made all men think think of
things differently now you know you so
you see these guys they're trying to
make it not just about them it's really
all men this is insulting and degrading
and if you can't see why it's insulting
and degrading then I I don't even know
if there's any way for me to explain it
to you
it should be self-evident why this is
insulting integrating the vast majority
of men do not need and did not ever need
the me to
movement to tell them not to rape women
or to harass women okay
the me2 movement came about because
perverts in Hollywood were being
perverts were being were being jerks or
worse most of us didn't learn anything
from that because we already knew it so
and no no I'll tell you right now I did
not learn a single thing from the me2
movement I learned nothing from it
Harvey Weinstein Kevin Spacey all these
guys Bill Cosby I didn't learn anything
from that I learned absolutely nothing
because I already knew all of that so
there wasn't any point where I was
sitting down and watching a news report
about Harvey Weinstein and and I went oh
man oh so we're not supposed to do that
okay whoo all right no I
that never happened for me I never had
that moment probably 95% of all the men
in the world never had that moment
because we already knew that and in fact
the thing is I would say actually 100
percent of men in the world never had
that moment because even the men who do
those things already knew that they
weren't supposed to do it it's not like
they were confused about it that's one
of the problems with this ridiculous
thing you hear from feminists about well
we need to teach boys not to rape let's
teach boys not to teach them not to rape
what do you really think that you need
to sit down and say to boys hey listen
don't rape people I mean do you are you
gonna sit them down and say hey listen
don't be serial killers okay I want you
to listen very closely to me right now
listen listen what I'm saying
do not rob banks don't do it no you
don't need to ever say that to really
anyone explicitly and I know you'll say
well people do those things yeah they do
them but they know they're not supposed
to do them yet they do them anyway you
know why because there are evil people
in the world who know that things are
evil and yet do those evil things anyway
because there's something else that they
want okay so an evil person will say I'm
gonna rob the bank anyway because I know
I'm not supposed
do it yes but I really want the money or
a very evil person will say I know I'm
not supposed to rape but I'm going to do
it anyway because that's I'm going to
fulfill this dark and depraved desire so
it's this it was never a matter of
confusion
all right that's a very important point
here second again the majority of men
will already do this so so think of the
the in that ad the sort of virtuous
courageous things that they show men
doing breaking up fights stopping
bullying refraining from sexually
harassing the majority of men will
already do that that's how the majority
men already act now the ad says some men
do these things which think of how
insulting that is
so they're showing these really basic
decent things and they're showing human
beings just acting like human beings and
then the ad says well sure
some men already do these things some in
fact the add twice gives this example of
a grown man breaking up a fight between
kids and it portrays this as some sort
of in fact I think it gives that example
three times actually and it portrays
this as some sort of rare example of
manly courage except almost every adult
man I've ever met in my life would do
that if you're walking down the street
and you see some some kid getting beat
up by a bunch of other kids getting
picked on of course you're gonna step in
what the people who made you let do they
think that most men are really gonna
stand by and watch it happen to say yeah
get him bully him do some more bullying
yes we love bullying really the people
who made this head I'm not sure if
they've ever met a man in their life
which is kind of concerning considering
they make razor blades for a living now
unless the fight is actually just a
couple of kids roughhousing and playing
around and having a good time
which yes boys ought to be able to do
that because yes boys will
boys in one of the scenes of the ad we
see a man and this is supposed to be an
inspiring moment a man runs in he's at a
barbecue he runs and he swoops in
because two little boys are kind of like
rolling around in the grass and they
appear to both be sort of smiling and so
this man he's he runs you know he says
he's at the grill and he drops ELISA he
runs over and stops them and separate
someone says oh that's not how we treat
each other okay no see ya there that
that's where most men or I would hope
anyway if they see a couple kids
roughhousing out in the grass they're
outside yeah you're gonna let them do
that because it's not a big deal that's
but that's how boys like to play when my
son gets together with his little cousin
who's they're about the same age I mean
you they just beat the crap out of each
other I mean it's they're like a couple
of they're like a couple of like rabid
raccoons going at each other but it's
they're having fun it's it's a that's
just how boys play right if it gets
really dangerous or something or if
they're about to break something then
we'll we'll stop them but but otherwise
you you you you let boys do that because
actually boys will be boys is in fact a
really important piece of wisdom boys
will be boys is not a slogan of toxic
masculinity it may be a cliche but like
many cliches it contains some very
crucial insights you know what I'm not
sure aside from in ads like this or in
movies or TV shows I'm not sure if I've
ever heard anyone sincerely offer boys
will be boys as an excuse for actually
bad behavior like I've I realized I've
never heard anyone say when we're
talking about rape or actual bullying or
anything laughs I've never heard someone
say well you know boys will be boys
that's that's not real it's not a thing
nobody says that in any situation I've
been in where this phrase boys will be
boys or something like it comes up it's
when we're talking about things that
boys should be
able to do boys do have aggression they
have energy they you know they have they
have creativity they need to be able
they need an outlet for these things and
you can't constantly be stifling and
suppressing all of that because you do
need boys to be boys and this is
something that parents of boys need to
understand and I feel really I feel very
sorry for boys who have parents who
think that boys will be boys is some
sort of horrible phrase that excuses
terrible evil I feel very sorry for boys
with parents like that because those are
boys who are not going to be allowed to
be boys and if you're not allowing your
boy to be a boy then what are you doing
you're forcing your boy to act like a
girl and that is not fair you let your
girl act like a girl don't you a third
thing can just imagine for a moment a
similar ad but for women what you can't
imagine it because no such ad would ever
be made no such ad could ever possibly
exist can you imagine an ad that said
that said some women act act right you
know some some women act the right way
can you imagine an ad like that can you
imagine an ad that showed various scenes
of women acting horribly and then it
allows at the end of concession some
women act the right way and this is an
ad for like Dove body wash or something
like that or it's I don't know what you
know a tampon commercial me okay can you
imagine an ad like that it couldn't
because you know what would happen
feminists would literally be rioting in
the streets they would be burning the
product in the street they'd be making
like Molotov cocktails out of it and
tossing it in people's windows I mean
they that's how upset they would be an
ad like that at an ad that degraded and
demeaned and insulted women like that
and talk
down to them and insinuated that most
women don't know how to behave like
decent human beings can you imagine an
ad that used the phrase toxic femininity
can you imagine anyone using that phrase
toxic femininity what if I were to start
using what if I were to start talking
about toxic femininity toxic femininity
that's that's when women gossip
maliciously about each other or when
women shop spend too much money so much
of the money on clothing or when a woman
acts just mean and nasty to a man that's
just trying to talk to her and make
conversation these kinds of things
happen all the time in society women act
like that all the time I'm not gonna say
most women do is but that certainly
happens we've all encountered women like
that have and we just like we've
encountered men who are jerks yet you're
not allowed to call that toxic
femininity are you and I would never
actually use that phrase because because
that's not femininity femininity is a
good thing
there is no toxic feminist like there's
no toxic masculinity there are men who
act the wrong way there are women who
act the wrong way but the women who act
the wrong way it's not because they're
being too feminine most of the time it's
precisely the opposite just like what
the men it's not that they're being too
masculine most of the time the problem
is exactly the opposite of that
but this yeah and and by the way when it
comes to like fights and things when
there's a fight going on and there are
people standing around cheering it on
listen I saw plenty of fights in high
school like many of us did and I can
tell you that girls are just as likely
to stand around and watch a fight and
cheer it on and laugh and record it on
their phone so they can put it on the
internet later I mean they they're just
as likely to egg it on I mean this is
something girls do too just like many of
the things that you saw in the ad and
the feminists blame men for is this
something that girls also do women also
do all the time you know feminists like
to complain about how men talk
and won't let them speak or let their
won't let them voice their own opinion
their own perspective well you think
women don't do that
all the time you think women don't talk
over men constantly as I've said before
it in situations where I you know in
most situations I've been in when there
are a group of people men and women
standing around or sitting around and
having a conversation it's usually the
women who do most of the talking
and if there's anyone involved who's not
allowed to get an ER wet a word in
edgewise it's usually gonna be the man
who can't not the women so I just don't
just doesn't make any sense all right
now that we've talked about about
masculinity let's look at why a lack of
masculinity can be harmful as I said the
problem with men it's not when they have
too much masculinity it's it's when they
lack it so let's look at an example for
that we turn to a man named Duncan Jones
director of various sci-fi films
Hollywood sci-fi films some good ones
like the movie moon which I think is one
of the best sci-fi movies the last 10 or
15 years and also some bad ones he
apparently directed Warcraft anyway he
decided that Twitter was the right forum
to vent his deepest parental
frustrations and so in a couple of
tweets which have now gone viral he had
this to say I'll read what he said he
said I have two kids two and a half two
and a half years and nine months old
respectively I'll tell you something I
never see anyone admit they are
exhausting frustrating and life
destabilizing they are rarely fun sure
smiles our great hugs are lovely but
it's hard and not obviously a good
choice in life and then he followed that
up with another way you said this is
where people feel compelled to say I
wouldn't change it for the world
but you know of course I'd reconsider
it's exhausting it's banal it's like
looking after a dog you can't
house-trained what it is is that it is
and they are mine hopefully they turn
out okay well I hope so too
Duncan but unfortunately the odds are
against them it seems if this is your
attitude about parenting what's most
concerning about these tweets is because
if you see a tweet like that and it's
just kind of lingering out there on its
own and nobody's reacting to it then
it's just whatever but these tweets
provoked a lot of reaction and in the
first day or so after they were
published a sizable portion of the
responses were entirely supportive and
sympathetic to what he was saying at
firt anão it's not like this and it's
not like this now if you look go look at
the tweets now because saying voices
have entered the discussion so it's it's
not the same now but originally if you
looked at these tweets and then you were
to read the thread I mean almost all of
the top like 20 or 30 tweets were
agreeing with what he was saying people
were parents decided that this was an
opportunity for them to come in and
enjoying the fray and kind of register
their own public complaints about their
children and their complaints were not
just the standard sort of parenting can
be tough type complaints but much more
specific and personal my life is
miserable and my kids are awful kinds of
complaints and and then you had some of
the people in the media wrote articles
about this there was an article in
Harper's Bazaar about it and the person
who wrote that article article said that
Duncan Jones's comments were very
important accurate and he should be
applauded for offering them well I'm not
sure that I can applaud I'm not sure I
can join the standing ovation here and I
say this as a parent of three kids to
five year olds one two year old so I'm
in the same basic phase of parenting as
Duncan Joneses and I look yes I will
agree that sure parenting is a challenge
you don't get a ton of sleep especially
in the beginning and that really that
can take a toll on you I mean that the
sleep thing really does wear you out
that's that's it that's a tough one when
you're not getting a lot of sleep and
there's a lot of crying and there's a
lot of noise and there's a lot of
movement and somebody is always asking
for a snack and when they get to be four
or five there are a million questions a
day I mean amidst there are always
questions and parenting is generally
expensive and it can be exhausting and
it can be anxiety inducing nobody thinks
and nobody would ever claim that
parenting is just this non-stop thrill
ride or it's or it's luxurious and
relaxing and all that you know nobody
would ever say that but worthwhile
things are never that way I can't think
of a single worthwhile thing that is
completely easy and relaxing and nothing
but fun the whole time there's not a
single worthwhile thing that is like
that so fine oh I'll give you all that
right but to say that parenting is
rarely fun like looking after a dog not
obviously a good choice if you see
parenting in those terms there is
something wrong with you
so this is not a thing of well he's just
voicing his opinion and you know that's
his opinion and he's being honest and we
should applaud them enough there's
something wrong with it it's actually
not okay to feel that way if you do feel
that way than you do right I mean but
what I'm saying is you shouldn't accept
those feelings and this is one of the
problems with with people sharing their
deepest most intimate emotions on the
Internet is that sometimes those
feelings and those perspectives and
those opinions are not actually okay and
so you shouldn't number one you
shouldn't be sharing them because it's
not anyone's business this is not the
forum for that so before we even get
into the specifics of the comment this
is not the forum that go talk to your
therapist talk to your spouse talk to
your priest I mean talk to somebody
personally you don't need to put it on
the internet and the
problem is when people have thoughts and
feelings like this and they put it on
the the reason why they put it on the
Internet is because they're looking for
other people to chime in and say oh yeah
I feel that way too and then all of a
sudden this feeling that originally
seemed to you to be kind of shameful now
you feel okay with it now you're now
you're going to sort of accept it
because you see that oh other people
feel the same way so it must not be that
bad if you're sitting around wallowing
in misery that parenting is disabling
your life and you would like to
reconsider those are not feelings that
you should just accept and embrace those
those are not good feelings they come
from a character defect in you and that
defect is pretty easy to identify
selfishness immaturity that's where it
comes from I mean if you rarely have fun
I cannot how can a person managed to
rarely have fun with like a two-year-old
to an two year olds are a blast and if
you if you haven't learned how to have
fun with them it's it's only because you
haven't had learned how to have fun or
that take joy in things that don't
revolve completely around you that's why
but once you've developed the ability to
actually look beyond yourself just a
little bit and to kind of like push your
own needs and desires just slightly
towards the back burner even for a few
moments it becomes extremely easy to
have fun with kids especially young kids
like I said my son is two years old and
the kid is he's also a challenge he's
going through his phase right now or he
has he breaks in these temper tantrums
randomly and for no apparent reason so
yeah that's tough that's not fun but
most of the time the kid is hilarious we
took him out in the snow yesterday to go
sledding and he loved it I mean it's
just how can you not have fun in that
situation unless again you demand that
every moment of your life center around
you because yeah with a two-year-old
it's not going to be like that these
these are these moments with your kid
when you're having fun with the two
they're not gonna be moments about you
they're gonna be moments about the
two-year-old all of these moments when
you're taking the two-year-old out out
to have fun you're gonna be caring for
the two-year-old watching after them
doing things that interest them and so
it's not gonna be about you that's true
but that doesn't mean you can't have fun
doing it
here's my experience kids are the most
difficult when you try to relegate them
to the background because kids don't
like being put in the background this is
one of the reasons why timeout or
sending a kid to a corner can can
sometimes be an effective form of
discipline now for you and me that would
not be an effective punishment because
we would say oh you want me to just go
chill in a corner for our great awesome
but kids don't like it because kids
don't like to be put they don't like to
be put in the background and to have
things going on without them they don't
want they can't handle that so that's
why and so when you're trying to do that
that's when it becomes the most
challenging and of course there are
times as parents when you need to be
able to put your kids sort of in the
background and do things that aren't
about them like you need to sleep you
need to work you need to sometimes have
adult conversations you need to spend
time with your spouse you need sometimes
to watch a movie that isn't about
talking animals or princesses you need
all of that right your whole you you you
can't structure literally every single
moment of your life around the kid and
when you're trying to have those moments
that aren't about them that's when they
can feel especially frustrating
especially burdensome but I think if you
find that your kids are always
frustrating and always a burden and
rarely fun and generally life
destabilizing that's probably because
you're trying to keep them in the
background and out of the way pretty
much all the time if you find no joy in
parenting at all it's almost certainly
because you've made no effort to
actually focus on your kids and invest
yourself in them you're trying to live
your life as if they don't exist and if
you try to live a life like that yes
kids will absolutely destabilize that
kind of lifestyle there's no question
about it so
one quick example of this right now one
of our parenting challenges in my house
is that my daughter five years old
refuses to go to bed at night okay it's
a very common problem many parents have
gone through it and so we'll put her
down for bed and then she'll find a
reason to come out of a room and come
talk to us like 9 or 10 times she keeps
coming out of a room finding a reason
she wants to tell us something she want
a drink of water she's got to go to the
potty she's you know there are monsters
under the bed there's this and that and
this and so this gets annoying because
as a parent you know when you put your
kids down the bed you want to kind of
clock out right you want to punch the
timecard clock out parenting is done for
the day
now you're gonna relax read a book watch
a TV show spend time with your spouse
you don't want a parent anymore you want
to be done with the parenting for the
day right when you put the kid down and
when they keep coming out and talking to
you and asking questions and wanting
things it just it's a it's way more
annoying than it would be at any other
time of the day because in your mind
you're saying no this is supposed to be
me time this is not you time this is me
time and now you're intruding on me time
and so even a even a really basic
question or need that you have is going
to be 10 times more annoying because
this is me time so here's what I found I
found that just a little bit of patience
and I'm not saying that I'm great with
patience ok I'm not I'm not a very
patient person I've had to work on this
I've been forced to work on it and I've
not mastered it at all but a little bit
of patient just a little patience with
with kids and suddenly this challenge
really becomes not a big deal if you can
just man it'll patience I'd say like 90%
of the problems that parents whine about
and then I whine about - sometimes just
a little patience would solve that
problem or at least make it so it
doesn't seem like as big of a problem a
little bit of patience so first of all I
realized that honestly it's not that big
of a deal if she comes out of a room and
says something that goes back in over
him it's like really not that huge of a
deal also again with a little bit of
patience I discovered that ok part of
the reason why this is happening is
because she has trouble sleeping at
night which means she's a lot like me
I'm kind of a night owl as well and she
has very specific needs for
we discovered she needs it to be very
dark she needs it to be cold she needs
to be wearing certain pajamas she needs
a fan on for the noise you know all
these so we just you know over time we
discovered and now we do that we put her
down for bed and so it's less of a
problem but she still comes out but it's
less of a problem and how much of a
problem was it really in the first place
is the question and that's the thing
about having young kids is that I
realized that even the things that are
super annoying and frustrating now I
realize and kid parents with older kids
they say this all the time and I and I
know that even though I haven't
experienced it I know that what they're
saying is true that even these things
that are annoying and frustrating now
when my kids are older I will miss
almost all of it I know that I will I'll
probably miss it terribly I mean there
will come a time when my daughter is not
gonna come out of her room and ask me to
carry her back down to her room and tuck
her in like that's gonna the times gonna
come when she has no interest in that
and and that's gonna be it's gonna be
sad when that phase is gone and over so
part of this with parenting I think is
just you know it's just choosing how to
think about these sorts of things there
are some parenting challenges which are
really just difficulties and hardships
and so all you could do is get through
them there's no you know there's there's
no way around it there's no rethinking
it there's no thinking of it differently
there are some things you go through as
a parent that you definitely will not
miss right but like not getting any
sleep when you have a newborn that's one
of that you're never gonna miss that
that's just that's just a hard thing but
a lot of this stuff if we just thought
of it differently we would see it as a
blessing as an as an opportunity for for
joy and and for fun GK Chesterton said
that an inconvenience is just an
adventure wrongly considered and I think
that that's true for a lot of parenting
parenting that kind of sums up a lot of
a lot of what parenting is David Foster
Wallace in a famous commencement speech
he gave talks about how many of the
situations that we find annoying and and
difficult in life
if he wasn't talking about parenting but
it goes for parenting too that many of
those situations if we just thought
about them differently had a different
attitude about them we would suddenly
see thee and this is the these are the
words he used we would see these moments
as not only meaningful but sacred and I
think he's right about that so I'm not
saying that we should be focused 100% on
our kids all the time you know they need
to know though the world doesn't revolve
around them - but but it also doesn't
revolve around us as parents and when I
hear from guys like Duncan Jones what it
sounds like is he wants the world to
revolve around him and kids they really
do think the world revolves around them
but they have an excuse to feel that a
two-year-old thinks that there's no way
a two-year-old isn't going to think that
because they have no concept of the
world outside of themselves so they're
allowed to think that way you're not
you're an adult you should know better
and here's the thing that there's not
enough room in the house for all for all
of us to be kids like someone's got to
be the adult in the situation sometimes
as an adult we have to you know we that
doesn't mean we can have fun acting like
kids with our kids sometimes having fun
with them but what I mean is we can't
have the attitude and the maturity of
children someone's got to be an adult
finally a seed we have time for this I
guess so yeah I just want to mention
this yesterday Donald Trump had the
Clemson football team over to the white
house but he couldn't get the normal
catering service because of the shutdown
so he provided this gorgeous classy
spread of McDonald's food I don't know
if you saw this picture take a look at
the picture of the feast right now now
of course people found a reason to be
upset about this I mean he's got the
silver platters filled with Big Macs and
and the fish fillets and french fries
and chicken nugget apparently there was
pizza - he provided Burger King as well
in case you were a Burger King guy not a
McDonald's guy people found a reason to
be upset about it
because they always find a reason
especially as a pertains to
Trump but really I mean first of all I
have long suggested that McDonald's
should have a buffet restaurant there
should be there should be Mick buffets
and they should look exactly like this
feast
so people have always called me crazy
for some but now you can look at this
and now you see what I'm saying right I
mean that would be great
it'll be a great kind and I'm talking
about a fancy like like what Donald
Trump did a fancy Mick buffet um so that
you could go there for your wedding
anniversary or you know a first date you
really want to impress a girl bring it
to the McDonald's buffet and you could
say to her hey have two Big Macs if you
want but secondly what what man what
football player what American wouldn't
love to be presented with a silver
platter filled with Big Mac and fish
fillets I mean anyone would love that I
have in my time been to many fancy bank
went banquet type things and I've had a
lot of fancy banquet food and I can't
think of a single one of those events
that would not have been vastly improved
by Big Macs I actually think that the
typical fancy banquet food is is usually
really disappointing the chicken tastes
like rubber the beef is always
overcooked they get way too fancy they
try way too hard portions aren't big
enough I would just take a Big Mac so I
actually think in all seriousness this
is although the left is making fun of
him for it of course I think this is
probably the most endearing thing that
Trump has ever done and if I ever went
to visit Donald Trump before some sort
of fancy lunch and McDonald's was not
served I would be thoroughly
disappointed this is exactly what I
would expect and I would be thrilled by
it alright we'll leave it there have a
great day everybody we'll talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed